>> HOLEVOET: Okay, hello, everyone.
My name is Dan Holevoet and I'm an engineer
on Google's developer relations team and I'm
going to talk to you today about building
context-aware extensions for Gmail, a deep-dive
on writing Gmail contextual gadgets.
So while I'm presenting here, we're going
to use Wave and Google Moderator.
So if you have any questions, you can feel
free to open up this URL and enter those inside
of the Google Moderator gadget that we have
running there.
There'll also be live notes and so you can
feel free to follow along.
And if you missed the URL or, you know, accidentally
closed your tab, you can find this on the
session site with this talk as well.
So a brief agenda, you know, why contextual
gadgets?
You know, why are you all here?
Why do you care about what I'm saying?
You know, why are contextual gadgets great?
And then what makes a contextual gadget?
So there are three pieces: gadgets, extractors,
and application manifest.
How to test and distribute contextual gadgets?
Common tasks and best practices that, you
know, will help you along the way as you're
writing these.
An example application that uses contextual
gadgets to sort of highlight some of the ways
that these are used.
And then finally, hopefully, I'll convince
all of you to go out and start writing these
so, some tips on getting started.
So first, why contextual gadgets?
Okay, so how many of you use Google Apps?
Lots of hands, yes, excellent.
Okay, how many of you have use Gmail?
All right, yeah, the same number.
Okay.
How many of you spend lots of time in Gmail?
Okay, okay, yeah.
So, you can probably imagine that, you know,
when you're in your Gmail that you get tons
of email everyday and, you know, a lot of
those emails convince you to, you know, load
up another one URLs.
They'll ask you a question about something,
and you go off in, you know another tab and
look for something, and then you'll find it,
you know.
Maybe you'll make some edits on a document
and, you know, some other application.
Then you'll come back and you'll send a response,
right?
This is a lot of different steps and they
all encourage you to leave your inbox.
And if you're like me, you manage the things
that you have to do by staying in your inbox.
And so leaving your inbox takes up time.
It's a little bit of a context switch and,
you know, it's generally unproductive.
So contextual gadgets allow you to stay inside
of your inbox and do all the things you have
to do on your daily basis.
So a great example of this is the Google Docs
gadgets, right?
And so you can see that here, I have an email
from John.
It's an important document.
And, you know, he sent me a link to it, right?
So I can click on that link and I can load
up Google Docs in a different window, read
the document, maybe make some edits, and then
come back and reply to him.
Or, you know, I could use this Gmail contextual
gadget, load up a preview of the document
right inside of Gmail, you know, read the
document, you know, do whatever it is that
I need to do inside of that email or inside
of that document, and then send off a reply
to John, all without leaving the context of
my inbox, right?
So I save a couple of extra steps here and,
you know, my day moves along a little bit
faster than it would have otherwise.
So what it is contextual gadgets do, right?
So this is one example of one.
Generally, they're matching on fields of an
incoming email message so who the message
is to, who the message is from, the subject
of the message, parts of the email message
body--things like links or images.
And then based off of those matches, they
trigger a gadget to appear.
And the context that we just matched in this
email message then gets passed into the gadgets
so that you can do something useful like display
a link to a Google Doc and display the contents
of that document.
So, what makes up a contextual gadget?
So, here's basically how Gmail looks normally,
right, or my artistic rendition of what Gmail
looks like normally, right?
And so this is what it appears like on a daily
basis.
You have, you know, your different labels
on the left, you have a Search Bar on the
top, and you're looking at this email thread,
right?
So we have this message loaded up at the bottom.
We can read that and we can do all sorts of
things with it.
So what happens when we add contextual gadgets
to this flow?
So I'm going to throw a bunch of terms at
you.
You don't have to remember all of them now.
I'll explain them all in just a moment, but
this is the basic idea of what's happening
when we use one of these contextual gadgets.
So, this email message, the one that we're
looking at the bottom here, is going to get
passed to what we call an extractor.
And that extractor is going to basically,
you know, use a regular expression to pull
out relevant bits of this email message.
Those are going to go to a filter, which is
basically a second layer of regular expressions
to really hone in on the important details
of this email message.
And then finally, we're going to make a decision.
Are there matches on this email message?
In most cases, no, there's no match.
So what do we do?
We don't do anything.
It looks the same as it always does.
Gmail doesn't change.
Your workflow doesn't change.
You just have an email message.
But in the case we do have a match.
Those matches are basically the context and
that triggers the gadgets and that context
is passed into the gadget.
All right, so these terms that I mentioned,
right?
So each contextual gadget is made up of three
things.
The first one of those is the gadget itself.
The second thing is one or more extractors,
and I'll explain those in just a second.
And then finally, because all of these extensions
or contextual gadgets are delivered as part
of the Google Apps marketplace, we have an
application manifest file, which basically
describes all of the pieces of the application
and ties them all into one application.
So what are gadgets?
Was anyone at my talk earlier today--is this
a refresher for some of you?
Okay.
I'll try and go through this a little bit
more quickly.
If anyone thinks I'm going too fast, feel
free to ask me a question.
So gadgets are XML, HTML, and JavaScript.
This is a really simple example of a gadget
"Hello World," "hello world example" is the
title of the gadget.
On top of that, we have some gadget-specific
features that allow you to do things like
adjust the height of the gadget, you know,
make it bigger or smaller, depending on the
content.
We have some classes for fetching remote data.
Those give us some helper features, like if
we want to sign a request that we know it's
coming from Gmail.
We can do that.
We also get some unique information about
the viewer.
So a unique ID that we can use inside of our
database.
And I'll talk a little bit more about that
in a few minutes.
And then we have helpers who are, you know,
accessing data like JSON.
If we've request JSON inside of this method,
we get back a JavaScript object that we don't
have to do any additional work on to actually
consume inside of the gadget.
And then finally, the piece that makes this
different from regular gadgets that you might
have seen in other places is this Google Content
Match feature, which is basically what returns
the context when one of these emails triggers
a match.
So the next piece of a gadget is the extractor.
And extractors are essentially Perl-compatible
regular expressions.
I mean that's the easiest way to think about
them.
And they come in two kinds or two varieties.
The first of those is the pre-canned extractor
where Google's actually done all of the work
for you, so if you want to pull out a specific
field of an email message like who the message
is from or, you know, who the message is to,
you can use a pre-canned extractor for that.
And on the second kind is the custom extractor.
So most of these pre-canned extractors operate
on a single entity, right?
So if I want to match in the context of an
email subject, like if I'm looking for, you
know, all of the subjects or all of the emails
that have "Hello World" in the subject, I
can use the pre-canned subject extractor.
But if I also want to know the subject of
an email and then also who sent it, I really
want to use a custom extractor.
And the reason for that is that the normal
relationship when you're defining multiple
extractors is an "OR" relationship.
So it's, if this extractor finds a match or
if this other one finds a match.
And a custom extractor combines those into
an "AND" relationships.
So, you know, if this is the subject and this
is the sender of the email then trigger the
gadget.
And so these aren't actually available right
now but they're available very soon.
And actually for people that are on the audience
today, if anyone is interested in testing
custom extractors, come and talk to me afterwards
and I'll see if I can hook you up.
So back to pre-canned extractors for just
a moment; this is the comprehensive list of
pre-canned extractors that we have available,
things like email addresses, the time an email
was sent, HTTP links, recipients, and even
USStockTicker if you're interested in pulling
those out of an email message.
And, you know, if there's something in this
list that we're not offering, we're really
interested in, you know, hearing what types
of things you'd like to have access to that
aren't available yet.
We'll see if we can add those to that list.
So, you might be saying, "Okay, well, a subject
extractor is cool, but it looks like it's
pulling out the subject of every single email
message.
And that would be true, right?
So if you want a match on just a subset of
all the subjects of email messages, you can
use what's called a filter.
And like I was saying in my diagram before,
a filter is basically a second regular expression
that hones in on the specific things that
we're really interested in looking for.
And it's really straightforward to use one,
so in this particular case here, this larger
piece is the extractor definition, which will
live inside of the application manifest.
And we're specifying the field that we want
to filter, in this case, it's the subject.
And we're looking for every message that says
"Hello World" at the beginning of the subject
line.
So if we were to actually apply this to someone's
inbox, only--we would only trigger the gadget
when the subject says "Hello World" at the
beginning.
As I said before, if you'd like to combine
the results of multiple pre-canned extractors,
you would write a custom extractor.
And that's useful for defining the "AND" relationship.
So this is an example of one of those customer
extractors.
This pulls out both the time an email was
sent, as well as the sender of the email message.
And actually, if you want it to then apply
filters to these, you could do that.
So you could say "param name equals sender
email," and specify a regular expression for
matching on that particular email address
so if you wanted to trigger on all the emails
from a certain domain, or certain sets of
domains, or everyone named "Bob," you can
do that inside of a filter.
So the final piece of these contextual gadgets
is the application manifest.
And this is, like I said before, what defines
the components of the contextual gadgets.
So you have definitions for the extractors,
you know, filters on any pre-canned or custom
extractors, the gadgets that are triggered
when those extractors find matches, and finally,
the scopes for data access.
So for each of these fields of the email message,
you have to basically indicate to the domain
administrator that's installing this gadget
that your gadgets are going to be looking
or, I'm sorry, applying a pattern to the fields
or that field of an email message.
So this is an example.
These are some examples of the different fields
of the manifest.
So the first one we're looking at here.
This is a test extractor and we're defining
basically where the extractor lives.
This is the test extractor ID.
We have a field here, and we're applying a
filter to it.
This is basically the same as what we're looking
at before.
We trigger a gadget, which is defined below.
So we indicate that by this trigger field
here.
And then below, we have the definition of
the gadget, which is basically a unique identifier
for the gadget as well as a link to the publicly
available gadget XML.
And then finally, we're declaring that this
extractor uses a scope.
So again, just like we referenced the gadget,
we're going to reference the scope, which
is available later on in the manifest.
The next slide has an example definition of
a scope.
So, in this particular case, we're looking
at the subject line of the email message here
and so the regular expression and the filter
that we've declared for this would then look
for matches on the subject lines and to trigger
the gadget.
And then, below that, we're actually specifying
a reason that the subject line is used by
the gadget.
So in this particular case, given that this
is an example, it's not a particularly descriptive
reason.
But when the application administrator goes
to install one of these contextual gadgets,
they would see a screen somewhat like this.
So, for each of the scopes reference in the
manifest, you would see the definition of
the scopes.
So something like mail, when the email was
received, and then that reason field would
display below that particular scope.
And so that's the way for the gadget author
to basically indicate to the domain administrator,
you know, why they're interested in having
any access to that particular field.
So, you know, basically, how these gadgets
work.
How do you test them?
How do you distribute them?
So the flows relatively straightforward and
I spell it all on the slide here, but I can
actually switch over to the marketplace and
show you how you would install one of these.
Kara 13:30 So I'm logging with my testamine
right now and I actually have a vendor profile
already set up, so we'll just click on this
and it will load.
And, all right, so I have a bunch of listings
here.
So I could create a new listing for my contextual
gadget, but since I already have on available,
we'll just load that one up right here and
you can see all the fields that I've entered
here.
So, the first thing that's important, this
is a product that is directly installable
into Google Apps domain so you check the first
box here.
You can pick a category for your application,
give it a name, give it a summary and an overview.
And then finally, you put in this application
manifest in the field here and this is basically
the document that I was talking about before.
So this is what gives all the scopes.
This is what defines the extractors we're
going to use and most importantly has a link
to the gadget that's going to trigger when
one of these extractors finds a match.
And you can, you know, put enterprise and
terms of service.
So don't blame me for breaks, et cetera, et
cetera.
You probably want to have your lawyers think
of something a little bit more rock salt than
that though.
All right, so then, we'll go back to the listing
page here.
All right.
So I can then click on this and if I were
ready to submit this to the marketplace right
now, I could click on this button.
There's a one time fee for listing in the
marketplace of a $100.
But since I'm not ready for that, I can still
add it to my domain.
So, yeah, normally, I would just type in my
domain here and this would walk me through
the installation flow which I just showed
you a second ago one of those, that screen
so basically it would show me the terms of
service, it would show me the data that's
being requested.
And then basically at the end, it asked me
if I'd like to enable the applications.
So I already have this application installed.
So we're not going to do that here.
But this is basically the install flow.
Oops.
So if you're developing for your own domain,
I don't know if anyone here is interested
in just writing contextual gadgets for themselves.
Anyone?
Okay, cool.
So if you're interested in doing that, the
flow that I just showed you is exactly what
you need to do and then once you have created
your test listing, you're basically done.
So you can install it on your own domain.
You don't have to pay a listing fee.
You don't have to publish it in the marketplace.
You don't have to worry about like other pesky
customers asking you difficult questions about
anything.
You can just install it on your own domain
and then you're done.
Right, so that's basically it.
You don't have to worry about any other distribution
or any other people trying to install your
gadget.
If you would like to sell it though, like
I said before you hit the publish button and
hopefully people will, you know, start pouring
in, installing your application on the domains,
and sending you lots and lots of money.
So, hopefully the business case is now being
made for why you would want to write one of
these.
So you're probably eager to get started.
So here is some best practices for while you're
writing this contextual gadgets.
So the first one of this is some notes on
using extractors.
So you should use the pre-canned extractors
if it's all possible, right?
They're fairly powerful.
You can do lots of things with them, and we
really try to take all the hard work out of
matching on particular fields, so use this
as we can.
If you can't, well, you know, let us know
if there's something that you'd really like
to do that you can't do yet, you know, a particular
thing that you're trying to match on and then
email and it just doesn't seem like it's possible
yet, so we love to hear that feedback.
The next thing is to use the smallest necessary
scope that you can while you were matching
this data.
So if you want to pull something out of the
subject line and you want to pull something
out of the sender email, don't ask for access
to the message body, right?
Every additional scope that you request to
access for is an additional roadblock that
you're going to have to cross when a domain
administrator is installing one of these applications,
right?
They may be comfortable giving you some access
to the subject line and a sender but maybe
not be so comfortable with access to a message
body, right?
So don't ask for extra data, basically.
And then finally, you should try and match
on these few emails as possible.
And you're probably thinking why I have this
really great use-case but it involves matching
in every single email message.
Fair enough.
I'm sure you do have a really great use-case
that does that.
But there are a lot of other people that do
it as well.
And it's not the greatest user experience
when you have one email triggering, you know,
five or six or ten contextual gadgets all
below that one email message, so just keep
that in mind; so sort of piggy backing in
that, some great tips for writing your gadget
UI.
So the first one, if your gadget doesn't have
anything to show, handle it gracefully, right?
So say, you are matching at every single email
message but, you know, there's no data in
your database or you can't find anything about
the particular field that you're matching
on.
If that's the case, collapse your gadget down,
use the dynamic type of call that I was just
mentioning a few minutes ago or, you know,
show a little teeny descriptive message saying
that there's no data for this particular message.
Don't take up the entire UI saying, "Oh, sorry,
I don't have anything to do," because you're
taking up the precious user's screen real
estate state and they're not going to appreciate
that and they may even go as far as actually
uninstalling your gadget, and you don't want
that and we don't want that.
So try and take up as little space as possible.
Be kind to the user.
And along those lines, it's really helpful
if you provide an option to users to expand
or collapse the gadget UI and actually remember
the user's preference.
So if I have one gadget that's triggering
on a whole list of emails inside of my [INDISTINCT]
thread that I'm looking at, it would be really
great if users could choose to collapse those
contextual gadgets that are showing up.
And the next time that they learn an email
thread, they already start out collapse and
the best way to do that is using the user
prefs API.
I don't actually have any code for that on
the slides but, if you want to know how to
do that, you can feel free to ask me at the
end and all, you know, live codes something
out for you.
And then, you know, along all these lines,
when you're talking about shrinking and expanding
the size of the gadget, the gadget's start
window.adjustHeight calls is really your friend
there and that's the easiest way to do that.
So for anyone that was here before, I talked
about fetching data, so I'm going to really
quickly run through this.
If anyone has questions on this, yeah, feel
free to ask me to expand on this a little
bit later.
So the way that we do this is using "osapi.http"
and this supports all the HTTP method.
So in this case, we're using a "get", you
can also use "post" or "put" and we're requesting
data at example.com, it's JSONs, we're going
to get back JavaScript object.
And because this is a synchronous, it's not
going to block the browser while it's executing.
So we're going to pass in a call back function
that's going to handle the data when the data
is returned and then the gadget can do some
useful event.
So this request gets made, proxies that request
to the gadget container that get sent along
to a remote site whether it's App Engine.
As it is in this case, a third-party site,
your own Web server something else.
You know, any site that's accessible on the
Internet will work find here.
The server sends back the, or it receives
a request that sends back the data and finally
the data gets passed to the gadget, it's pretty
straightforward.
Along those lines, you can actually use the
same flow if you'd like to do authentication
of the currently signed in user.
And so the key for this flow is that we're
adding the, of the sign parameter into this
request and so what that basically does is
when this request gets to the container, so
after it's passed through beyond the user
so that the user can no longer edit the request.
You know, it's free of, you know; worry to
be of being mangled by, you know, a clever
user and a JavaScript console or anything
like that.
The container will actually append unique
user ID, which we call the OpenSocial ID on
to the end of the request.
Basically, mash all the parameters and the
request together or any data that's in the
payload and then cryptographically sign it.
So this is using a shared secret between the
gadget developer, you know, you and Google.
So you're the only two people that will have
access to that key.
So the signature that's at the end basically
signifies that none of the data was edited
in transmission and that the user that has
identified is actually the user that's using
your app, right?
And so once this gets to the server, the server
can basically duplicates that signature process,
basically mash all the parameters together,
add any of the payload content into this basically,
you know, it's a giant string and then repeat
that signing process to make sure that the
signature that results is the same signature
that was passed along in the request.
And then, you know, it repeats as it did before.
So the data gets returned to the container
and the data gets passed back to the gadget.
So you say, "Okay, that's cool.
But the OpenSocial ID is not particularly
useful."
What would I do if I want more than the OpenSocial
ID?
So this is fairly common.
And because all of these applications are
part of the Google Apps Marketplace, you are
already using OpenID to do authentication
for other parts of your apps, so we're going
to encourage everyone to use OpenID for authentication
within a gadget.
And so the basic flow for this is this follows,
right?
So we have that same remote data request data
here, it's sign to passes in the OpenSocial
ID to server.
And here's some pseudo code Python like App
Engine code that you could use to basically
use that OpenSocial ID, so we'll take that
ID here.
We'll do a query on the user's table in our
App Engine app.
Basically, we'll see if there's anyone we've
already identified that has that OpenSocial
ID, you know, in datastore.
And if there isn't anyone, what we're going
to do is we're going to basically save that
OpenSocial ID along with a unique one-time
use token.
So this could be a session token.
It could be a random string, you know, any
value that you'd like as long as it is unique
and it only gets used the single time, right?
So we save that at datastore, and then we're
going to return to the gadget basically as
status message, right?
This user wasn't found.
We've created a temporary table in our database
and it's identified by this session token,
so that gets pass back to the gadget.
And we'll talk about what happens next in
just a second.
And the other case, where you have already
identified this user, you can send back a
message saying, "Yes, we know who the user
is."
You can also pass along some data.
You know, here's the user's email.
Here's their favorite color, things like that.
Whatever you've already collected in your
datastore, at this point, you can pass it
back to the gadget and use it in your gadget.
So what do you do?
What's the next step when you need to do further
authentication on the user, right?
So you have this single-use token that's been
passed back to you.
And you know if the OpenSocial ID is of the
current user.
And so what you're going to do next is you're
going to open up a popup window to whatever
location you're using until you handle OpenID
for your app, right?
So this could be your own server, it could
be a third-party server as it does OpenID
on your behalf.
Whatever it is, as long as it does OpenID,
you're good to go.
So you open up this URL.
You're passing the session token as a parameter
at the end and then the user goes to the OpenID
process.
And since this is part of the Google Apps
Marketplace applications, in this case OpenID
doesn't actually require the user to do anything.
You're already in Gmail so the person is,
the user has already signed in with their
Google Apps account.
So when they get to the step of doing OpenID,
they're already authenticated.
And because Google Apps Marketplace applications
can also whitelist the ROM that they're using
for OpenID, you don't actually require authorization
step either.
So this popup window will redirect itself
a couple times and finally end up on your
server with that session token appended to
the end of the URL.
And at this point, you know who the user is
because they've just logged-in via OpenID,
so you have access to their OpenID and, you
know, if you use Attribute Exchange, you have
access to things like users' email address.
And then because you pass in the session token,
you can also look up in your datastore the
OpenSocial ID that is associated with that
session token.
So, you know the OpenID, you possibly know
the email address and you know the OpenSocial
ID and you can save that all in your database.
So at this point, you know everything you
need to know about the user in order to do
authentication and then you can close the
popup window.
And since the popup was opened from within
the gadget, if you're pulling to see when
a popup is closed, you'll actually be able
to trigger some new behavior once the window
gets closed.
So this is sort of a [INDISTINCT] check sends
a request, talk to the server to basically
ensure that everything went the way that you
expected it to.
And if for some reason the user closes the
popup window before everything finishes, you
can throw, you know, a message saying, you
know, "Hey, you didn't actually authenticate
it.
We really need you to do that just once, we
promise, and then you can open the popup window
again."
Otherwise, you're all set.
You can run your gadget as you normally would.
So, next, some tips on writing safe gadgets.
So the first thing, probably the most important
thing here is to stick to the HTML and CSS
specs.
This is great for both security and compatibility
of your gadget.
So these gadgets will work across browsers.
And, you know, the best way to ensure compatibility
is by doing things as they are outlined in
the spec.
Along the same token, you know, stick to safe
DOM operations.
Don't do things like document "document.write."
Use supportive event handlers and timers and,
you know, in order to help you along in writing
these gadgets, we actually recommend that
you use things like Google Web Toolkit, OpenSocial
Templates, and jQuery.
So if you're using one of these things that'll
take care of most of the recommendation above.
So, just worry about jQuery and don't worry
about writing safe DOM operations you can
sort of trust what it's doing and you'll be
all right.
And a little bit of a distinct between these
gadgets and the ones I was talking about earlier
is that Gmail contextual gadgets will be using
Caja.
So how many people here know what Caja is?
Yeah, that's about right.
Okay, they're all Googlers.
So Caja is basically an added layer of security
for applications that live inside of, you
know, third party apps.
And, so, what they provide is basically a
whitelist of JavaScript, safe JavaScript operations
that can be executed by untrusted applications.
So for applications that are already inside
of iFrames, you know, they're protecting against
a smaller set of things but there are still
some things that that an iFrame doesn't protect
you against that Caja would protect you against.
And, if you're really interested in learning
more about this, you can go to this code hosting
project or project hosting site here, code.google.com/p/google-caja,
which we'll explain in some more detail.
It's a little bit out of scope of this presentation
but, more details than you can ever possibly
want to know about using Caja.
And, basically, if you're using one of these
supportive frameworks that we've outlined,
when we do turn on Caja inside of Gmail contextual
gadgets, your gadgets will work.
So if you use Google Web Toolkit, if you use
OpenSocial Templates, if you use jQuery, you're
good to go.
If you use something else, you might be good
to go, but you might not, so good to start
now and, finally, if you'd like to test any
of the JavaScript that you've written, there's
Caja playground at caja.appspot.com where
you can actually input some of your JavaScript
and see how it cajoles as it's named, so good
things to keep in mind for now.
And these are some examples of the good, the
bad, and the ugly when it comes to writing
JavaScript code.
These are very straightforward.
The last one in particular, you shouldn't
trust things like, you know, redirecting the
parent window to possibly untrusted data from,
you know, random users or anything that's
unsanitized and that goes for things not just
a redirection of the page.
But, if you're displaying content, make sure
that you sanitized it, everything that gets
put in to your gadget.
So, now, let's talk about an example application
that's using a Gmail contextual gadget.
And if anyone was here before, you've seen
this application a little bit already.
And this is an application I wrote, it's called
TicTrac, and it's a ticket tracking system.
Basically, it uses Gmail as a ticketing system,
so you can assign owners and statuses to your
email threads and then, you know, there are
some other gadgets that I wrote for the other
session where you can see a different dashboards
and so on, things like this, you know, that
give you a summary of activity inside of the
system.
So, let's look at the application really quickly.
Have it open one of these windows.
So this is basically the app, and we have
a bunch of people that are working on these
tickets.
They can click on one.
See the tickets that are assigned to me.
App Engine is taking a little time.
Okay, so here we go.
These are all the tickets that are assigned
right now.
It looks like I've resolved all and it's great.
And basically the flow would be, you know,
click on one of this messages, see who it's
from.
You can unassign it.
You can take; you can assign it to somebody.
Basically, say, "I'm working on it" and when
you're done, you can finally hit resolve.
And, so let's talk about how TicTrac is using
these contextual gadgets.
So TicTrac basically specifies an extractor
that filters on the list of recipients of
an email message.
So, in this particular case, I have a ticket
queue which is basically a Google Groups email
address, and whenever a message comes into
my inbox that sent to the list, I want to
identify that as one of the messages that
sent to this Ticket Tracking system.
And then, I'd like to trigger the contextual
gadget to appear.
Once we're inside of the contextual gadget,
we're going to take the sender of the email
as well as the time the email was sent and
shift that off to App Engine and, basically,
use that to pull out information about the
thread that that email is part of and send
that back to the contextual gadgets so that
we can learn interesting things about the
email message and possibly take some actions.
So this is a basic architecture diagram of
TicTrac and it's the familiar extractor filter
flow here on the right.
When there's matches, we trigger the gadget.
The gadget sends information to App Engine.
On the side here, we have email from these
groups being sent into App Engine as well
so that we can perform the matching between
the emails and the threads that they're part
of--excuse me.
And then finally, we're setting the thread
details back.
So, yeah, so let's look at this in action.
So, here I am, I'm in my inbox and I have
these two threads that look like they need
an answer.
So, the first one is we'll open up, the tricky
question, does P equal NP?
That is a tricky question.
And we can see, below here, we have TicTrac
being triggered, so we can see that the message
is new and basically it's unopened.
On the right side, we have it's unassigned
so no one is working on this.
I can't imagine why.
It looks like we need to take some action.
I really don't want this in my inbox, so let's
deal with this, let's triage these tickets.
So, I don't think I can answer this one, so
I'm going to pass it to one of my colleagues,
so I just type his username in there and I'll
sign it.
So, at this point, I haven't left my inbox.
I've assigned the email message.
Basically, I'm done triaging and I can just
take out of the follow-up label and we're
done.
So, when Ryan comes in later, he'll see that
he has a ticket to work on and he can get
work on solving that vital question.
So the next one, a simple question, oh, this
is much better.
So we can see here.
What is the air speed velocity of an unladen
swallow?
Oh, no one is working on this one yet.
This is excellent.
So I'll just take this one here.
I think I can answer this with another question
actually.
So let's see.
African or European, and we'll send that off,
and we're done.
So I can mark it as result and remove the
label and we're finished editing all these
tickets.
So I didn't have to leave my inbox.
I could see that no one was working on a message.
I could, you know, basically identify that
I was working on a message or assign it to
someone else.
Send off the email when I'm done with the
tickets resolved.
I can mark it as resolved and, you know, I
basically completed this entire workflow in
a couple of seconds without ever leaving the
context of the particular email message.
All right, applause, this is excellent.
All right, so how are we doing this?
All right, so the first step, we're using
the matches.
And this is really just boilerplate code.
You can actually copy this into your own contextual
gadgets and just start using it.
Basically, what this is going to do is, you
know, use as API call and get back an object
that has fields for each of the things that
we're pulling out.
So, in this particular case, I'm looking at
the time the time the email was sent as well
as you sent the email so I'm going to get
context.time_sent and context.sender, and
I can use those in map, it's really convenient.
So, once we have these two fields, we can
use this method that I wrote here called getThreadFromDetails,
which will take that context, pass it into
the method here.
This is another asynchronous call that's going
to send off a request to App Engine.
And, you know, basically, the result that
we're going to get back is some sort of thread
ID.
So, this is going to construct the payload
that's something like the following here.
This is just basically some JSON, not particularly
interesting, but if you're interested in writing
an API similar to this that takes inputs like
this, this is actually a really great article
on code.google.com and the App Engine section
about writing RPC APIs on App Engine which
is really great for gadgets like this.
And I can find the URL if anyone is interested
in that after the talk.
So this will send the request to App Engine.
We'll get back some data and then we can display
those buttons or the little status bar for
each of the tickets.
So it's really straightforward, the rest of
it is basically just writing some UI code.
And then the other interesting piece here
is that in the application manifest, we need
to declare the details of this particular
application.
So I'm using a customer extractor here because
I want to match only when we know the recipient
is in the list of addresses that we want to
match upon.
And then I'm also interested in collecting
the sender of the email as well as when the
email was sent.
So here we have the custom extractor.
We're triggering TicTrac gadget, which we'll
see in a second.
We're filtering on the recipient to email
address here.
So this is a regular expression for matching
on my mailing list, and then finally, we're
declaring the three scopes that are being
used by the gadgets so that's the time sent
and the time received as well as the recipients
of the email.
So this is the definition of the gadget, super
straightforward.
Basically, you just have to make sure that
this ID matches up with the, what we declared
earlier.
And then, you know, this is the gadget XML.
And then, you know, there's three of these
scopes.
This is just the first one of those three.
They're basically all the same.
We give a definite--oops.
We give the description of the, or basically
a unique name for this scope.
We have field definition here for the particular
scope that we're interested in looking at.
You don't have to memorize this or sort of
figure out what they all mean.
We have a list of them in our documentation,
you can just copy and paste.
And then finally we have a reason field, you
know, we're extracting the time sent because
we need to perform email lookup, so relatively
straightforward.
So hopefully that's seems relatively simple.
You guys seem to like it.
So, hopefully, you all want to get started
at this point.
So I'm happy to say that we launched contextual
gadgets on Tuesday, so you're all free to
start developing this today.
We have documentation on code.google.com/api/gmail/gadgets/contextual.
It's nice and hierarchical.
We also have documentation on the marketplace
so if you're interested in writing applications
that use other parts of the Google Apps Marketplace
you can feel free to check that out.
And then we have a developer form for writing
gadgets that live inside the Google Apps,
this URL here.
And, you know, thank you all for coming to
this last session of Google I/O.
It's, you know, it's a little bit late in
a day, so I'm happy you all stuck around and
came to this.
But there area lots of other enterprise sessions
as well so I'd really encourage everyone to
check those out too, and they'll all be posted
online.
And one thing is not mentioned in here is
that I like to give a huge shout out to all
the people that watched contextual gadgets
with us on Tuesday.
These are really great.
And if anyone wants to see some really great
ways to use contextual gadgets, I'd encourage
you to go bit.ly/getcontextual and you can
see all the integrations in the Google Apps
Marketplace so these are really awesome.
And without further ado, we will go to questions.
Let's see.
I thought there's a question here before.
Let's just refresh.
And, yeah, if anyone has live questions, feel
free to use the mics too.
>> Yes.
Actually, I would like to know a bit of a
limitation of the tool that you just shown
us.
Basically, can I reduce some kind of AdSense.
Did you see what I mean?
>> HOLEVOET: So, pull out the context from
an email message then to through your ads?
>> Right, right, right.
>> HOLEVOET: You technically could.
Let's just leave it at that right now.
I can get you the legal answer perhaps if
you give me your email address.
>> Okay, thanks.
>> Is it possible I have sort of like a configurable
extractors like, you know, for the gadget
you made, it's like, you know, at my mailing
list at, you know, your company.com but what
if, I'm in a different, I have a different
mailing list name, is there some support for
something like that?
>> HOLEVOET: Right, so, right now, the answer
is no.
But we're looking at ways that you could possibly
do something like that.
So if you have list somewhere that you want
to specify all the mailing list that you'd
be interested in and matching on, have some
way to specify and extract it that looks at
that list, but we don't have anything like
that yet.
>> Thanks.
>> HOLEVOET: Yup.
Hey.
>> Hello, again.
You mentioned some shared secrets in signing
for so that the, your encryption stuff.
>> HOLEVOET: Yup.
>> Do you have any more details about that?
Like, what sort of encryption, ramification
policy, exploration policy and the keys and...
>> HOLEVOET: So, if you're concerned with
using our shared secret, you can also RSA,
so that's probably the best thing to do in
that particular case, so we publish the key
and you can just use that for all the signing.
>> Cool.
Thanks.
>> HOLEVOET: Yup.
Okay.
Questions?
>> All right, going to your YouTube example,
that's all about what the recipient of the
email sees.
What do you have to say about what the authoring
experience might be?
I mean, obviously, if it say, "Link to a YouTube
URL," it's cut and paste the URL, but...
>> HOLEVOET: Right.
>> ...if you're in the Gmail editor what do,
it seems kind of limp.
>> HOLEVOET: Yeah, so, right now, these are
operating strictly on the recipient side.
We don't have contextual gadgets for authoring,
maybe we will.
I don't have anything in particular in mind
of that right now.
>> Okay.
>> HOLEVOET: Yeah.
>> I was wondering if you will be asking the
Android mobile client to include this kind
of features.
>> HOLEVOET: Right, so, right now, these won't
work inside of the mobile app.
I think it would be really cool if they did.
So, we'll see what we can do.
Yup?
>> Hi.
Does it mean that the gadget is will only
hook the emails inside the inbox or it will
hook also inside for emails to the other folders
including compose message?
>> HOLEVOET: So, during composition, it won't
show up.
But if I go to any other email that I perceived,
it will basically do the matching process.
>> Including the trash also?
>> HOLEVOET: Sorry?
>> Inside the trash, email in the trash, inside
the sent email?
>> HOLEVOET: It might not show up in the trash.
Actually, it's a performance thing just because
it seems like a good place to optimize.
But if you send an email message, you should
see a contextual gadget trigger on that as
it normally would.
So, after you sent it, if you go back to your
sent mail and load up one of the emails that
you've sent, if that would trigger a contextual
gadget that should show up.
>> Any plan to hook up the gadget for the
compose message also?
>> HOLEVOET: Not, I mean, there's no particular
plan that I can share right now, so.
>> All right, thank you.
>> HOLEVOET: Yup.
>> Just a quick, I guess, question request,
in the standard built-in ones, can we have
arbitrary head of match so if I wanted references,
for example because I knew it was an email
that came initially from me or being tagged
at a certain way for the message ID...
>> HOLEVOET: Right.
>> .. that I could, you know, use that as
a filter.
>> HOLEVOET: Right, so, right now, there is
not, ways to do on an arbitrary header.
We can certainly look into doing something
like that, and we'd have to figure out the
right way to message that inside of the scopes
so that the domain administrator knows what
types of things you're trying to extract.
>> Yeah, no worries.
>> So, hi, I was wondering you mentioned GWT
as a tool to write gadgets.
Having gone through the experience of, from
using GWT for running iGoogle gadgets and
breaking a few teeth on that, I was wondering
what the, if there's anyone actually written
gadgets for contextual gadgets in GWT?
>> HOLEVOET: Yes, I believe that there are
some people here that have actually written
in contextual gadgets and GWT and can speak
to that, yes.
Yeah, right on the back.
>> Excellent.
Thanks.
>> HOLEVOET: Yeah, cool.
>> And by the way, I'm, the header thing would
be great.
>> HOLEVOET: Yup.
>> Some header match.
>> HOLEVOET: Yeah, we've done that feedback
from a bunch of much people, so we'll look
into that.
>> Cool.
>> HOLEVOET: Yeah?
I guess, that I should do some of the...
>> How would the oldest handle privacy, right?
So if my boss who is the controller of the
Google Apps would enforce all users to use
a specific gadget that would eavesdrop on
all emails and send CCs to him so he can read
or maybe even trigger on his own name or...
>> HOLEVOET: Right.
>> ...or sexual reference, I don't know.
How would you, should do that?
>> HOLEVOET: Right, so let me very clear about
this.
The domain administrator is really the one
that's making the decision about what gadgets
to install.
And so, hopefully, your domain administrator
is the right person to be making that decision
but that's where the decision is being made.
So Google is not installing any of these on
your domains account and, you know, we're
not going to match some things like that.
So your domain administrator should make sure
that they understand what they're doing before
they click the button.
>> Okay, I understand.
>> HOLEVOET: Yeah?
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> HOLEVOET: It might have been today or very
recently, yeah.
So, yes?
>> Can I use the gadget [INDISTINCT]?
>> HOLEVOET: So, repeating the question for
the people who are watching the video.
Can you use the contextual gadget for basically
as a target to drop things from other places?
So, you could do that.
I mean, if you're using like HTML5 or something,
you can do anything you can with HTML5 inside
in one of these gadgets.
It's basically just a small webpage.
So you can certainly do that.
I guess the gadget would have to trigger first
before you could that.
If you want to do like a gadget in the Gmail
Fnav, you can also do something like that
too.
Yeah?
>> Sorry, right now, the example is using
the webmail of Google Mail.
If I'm using such software like Outlook, so
and the downloading is through POP3 or any
kind of protocol like that.
Would it be possible to add, to point some
text at the end of a mail received according
to the rules by the rule codes on the widgets?
>> HOLEVOET: I'm not sure if I understand
your question.
>> No, basically, let's say that I'm quoting
something which adds a text at the end of
a mail received.
>> HOLEVOET: Okay.
>> And it works on the webmail.
>> HOLEVOET: Right.
>> Would it work if I download the mail through
Outlook?
>> HOLEVOET: So the contextual gadgets not
actually going to change anything about the
email, it's just going to show up below.
And so that's, you know, its' going to be
triggered based off of the match in that email
message and that match is only going to show
up where contextual gadgets are available.
>> Oh, okay.
I see.
>> HOLEVOET: Okay, so I'm going to quickly
go through this live question, or a matter
of the questions here.
Does contextual gadget can create Gmail folders?
So right now, the only interaction with Gmail
itself is displaying at the bottom of these
email messages.
It's not actually changing anything in Gmail.
It's not changing setting, it's not changing,
you know, filters or anything like that.
So the answer for this one is no.
Any way to store preferences are saving the
cloud instead.
So I think in the context of gadgets, you
are saving to the cloud if you save it in
a gadget, and that would be the user prefs
API that I was talking about before.
There's documentation on that if anyone is
interested.
When enabling a third-party gadget [INDISTINCT]
limit, the gadget's access to specific fields.
So, the domain administrator cannot basically
deny parts of a request from a gadget, so
it's basically all or nothing, right?
You can decide to install a gadget that asks
for the site of fields that it's asking for
or you can, you know, deny access to that
gadget.
So, if the gadget is asking for every single
field of the email message, it's appropriate
to sort of wonder what the motivation is for
doing that.
But, you can't basically do a line of [INDISTINCT]
veto and the reason for that is basically
what if you eliminate a field that prevents
or that keeps the gadget from working.
So, now, you can do the one off restrictions.
It's basically yes or no.
For apps domains, how can you deploy to a
subset of users or user app out within a domain?
So right now, you can only deploy to all the
users in a domain and, you know, this is common
feedback so we're going to look at ways not
only at Google Apps or Gmail contextual gadgets
can be restricted to certain users but also
everything in Google Apps that's installed
will be in the marketplace.
And I think that's it.
So anymore live questions?
Yeah?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> HOLEVOET: Okay, so this is basically the
same as any other scope change inside of a
Google Apps Marketplace application.
So you would update your manifest and basically,
you know, remember the scopes or edit scopes
or add scopes, whatever it is that you're
interested in doing in particular.
And then, the domain administrator would need
to go in and basically re-approve that change
before it could take effect.
Yup?
Yeah?
>> How long do you [INDISTINCT] with the gmail.com?
>> HOLEVOET: Yes, I was waiting for something
to ask me that question.
So, unfortunately, we don't have a specific
timeline on when this would be available to
regular Gmail users.
There are some things we have to think about
before that could happen.
And, unfortunately, I don't have a timeline,
but, you know, I'm really excited about it
and I think it would be great to roll out
to everyone, but that's just my opinion, so
we'll see.
>> Going back to this question, did you, if
you change the scope and then did you guys
catch the apps or just disable the apps or
[INDISTINCT]?
>> HOLEVOET: Right.
>> Do some change in the application; the
administrator will be around to update it
for a week.
>> HOLEVOET: Right, so in the case of contextual
gadgets and one of the people in the audience
can correct me if I'm wrong in this.
But I believe if you change the scopes requested
by a contextual gadget, it would actually
disable the contextual gadget, is that correct?
>> Yeah, [INDISTINCT].
>> HOLEVOET: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> If you have an existing [INDISTINCT] not
exactly [INDISTINCT]
>> HOLEVOET: Right.
>> So you [INDISTINCT]
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> HOLEVOET: Right.
So the best way to do this is to basically
like adding a new feature.
So if you add a new feature to a Google Apps
Marketplace app, the other feature also going
to work, the new feature is just not going
to be turned on yet.
Okay.
Well, thank you all for coming.
And, yeah.